look as an operator behind closed doors
I'm talking to a lot of different
partners I'm talking to employees direct
reports and I'm seeing a lot of fear in
some people's eyes they're worried
they're concerned is this real some
people are really afraid market crash
that one below 30 000 will it go below
28. look where Bitcoins that look what's
going on with Russia and Ukraine is
there going to be a nuclear what's going
on with Armenia Azerbaijan Iran this is
a little scary I get it but at the same
time a climate like this exposes leaders
that panic and can't handle these types
of situations but it also discovers
leaders who all of a sudden everybody
says ow that guy makes me feel good that
guy seems very reasonable I'm gonna
follow this guy it's gonna discover
those types of leaders and we'll talk
about in this video by the way if you
get value from this video give it a
thumbs up and subscribe to the channel
so let's get right into it today what
what things that people don't see what
our cameras on in meetings people don't
see When leaders Panic there's a lot of
that going on anxiety you just feel
anxious being around them negative you
feel negative being around them they
just just want to kind of stay positive
I just want to stay positive I don't
want us to look at numbers I don't want
us to look at stuff just please can we
just stay positive can we just stay
positive and they don't have the
maturity to say no really we're going
through some of this stuff
and this bleeds into other people on
their teams fear all of that and next
thing you know everybody's kind of
panicking panicking panicking and
nothing good comes out of that happen a
matter of fact we were having a
conversation this morning I was doing a
meeting with minute which minute our app
is blowing up and we were having this
conversation with the guys and I said
listen in War what happens if we're in
war and when your battle buddies panics
and they're constantly panicking about
making mistakes you know what happens
when a battle buddy does that in war
people die okay units get killed when
someone panics but in war when you're in
war and things are not going right
there's so many different things going
on at the same time what happens when
somebody says listen guys here's what we
can't control here's what we can't
control let's go back to what we've
trained for and do this and if we do it
right we can win this little battle that
we got going on here so these types of
people get discovered and they become
leaders so for you today
I've gone through 2001 crash I've gone
through 2001 911 2007 2008 covet all
these different things Iran I watched my
debt all these different things I've
gone through when I was in Germany at a
refugee camp and I'm 11 12 years old
short term nothing's going right short
term I got cut stabbed in a fight I got
into it in Afghani I'm in Iranian is in
Afghani and there's a little bit of
battle there we got into a fight so I
don't have anything to look forward to
I'm loving living in Germany I'm having
a great time but what gave me a lot of
Sanity to overcome the pain wasn't the
short-term issues that we're facing
living in a refugee camp it was a long
term we're eventually going to end up in
America
and whether that's a year from that
two-year smoke doesn't matter long term
brought me peace when I'm in Iran and
we're going through the war in my desk
like everything's gonna be all right
long term short term it's going to suck
but long term it's going to be great
that feeling of long terms like you know
what what a perspective you're right you
go back to 1982 you know where Dow Jones
was in 1982 900. you know where Dow
Jones is at today 29 000. you know how
many times that is that's 33 times you
know what that means that means 40 years
from now in 2062 Dow Jones should be
around 900 000. give or take think about
what I just said to you if we go based
on that 40 years long term pretty much
everything works itself out however a
leader must know that to bring hope to
the team simultaneously address the real
issues that we can do something about to
highlight to the peers and challenge
peers to step up and do something about
it with a strategy with a challenge then
from there here
you go out there and execute during
times like this with a high level of
urgency very very much of a hope feeling
things are going to work out but
extremely urgent and a bit of paranoia
to say if we don't we could go out of
business I know all this stuff may be
like that's kind of a bipolar thing
isn't it it is but you need both of it
right you need somebody that's poised
calm ready prepared excited it's gonna
be fine I have faith I have hope but at
the same time guys let's go we ain't got
a lot of time let's go did you get that
stuff in did you get that let's go get
it we can do it that mentality needs to
be in the right place again we went
through this every five to ten years
this happens and every five to ten years
okay if you get exposed people get
discovered my challenge to you is for
the market to discover you as a leader
not as somebody that panics fears has
anxiety constantly when [ __ ] hits the
fan so having said that if this message
gave you value give it a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel and if you want
to go a little bit deeper into a message
like this watch the video I did two
years ago I think it's called the
difference between wartime leaders and
peacetime leaders having said that have
a great day to everybody take care bye
foreign